I don't consume without purpose my
escapism is the Jets other than that
when I'm on it for an hour I'm watching
why and I'm also breaking the algorithm
like I'll search random [__] like out of
nowhere tomorrow I'll just search
pickles and consume three pickle videos
I'm trying to break the algorithm to
give me Serendipity not give me what I
am looking at I don't need Jets videos
in there I need to like do what
consumers are doing so like literally
out of nowhere I'll just type in
sweaters hashtag click and then my for
you page will evolve because I'm
throwing it off because I'm using it for
market research I'm not a social media
consumer I'm a social media
Anthropologist and strategist and then
I'm a content creator